well you know she was an innocent and
she was what we oh I mean she's the girl
even though she did smoke pot which is
such an an anomaly for a good girl but
the way she smokes it you can see she's
not experienced you know she coughs and
she she sort of blows it if you will
it was the archetype that had to be the
center of that story which is an
innocent girl without boyfriends without
experience it's this per babysitter you
know the movie was conceived as the
babysitter murders I mean that's how
Mustafa Akkad went to John Carpenter and
said I want to make a movie about
babysitter's who get slash 'red and it
was John and Deborah who set it on
Halloween night and I think it was Debra
who said let's have it take place on
Halloween night but it's really the
innocence of babysitting coming into
conflict with this evil being and that's
why the movie worked was because she was
so incredibly vulnerable and the
audience was lit in on her vulnerability
from the very beginning I wish I had you
all alone oh poor Lorri scared another
one away you just are establishing this
girl with no experience and then you
know you put her in peril and it worked
she was a virginal character but she was
extremely strong and self-directed and
you know if it's mainly Jamie's
performance I think that's what what
took us there I think if you're good at
that I will tell you this the scariest
sequence in the new movie involves a
babysitter and it involves a babysitter
who's different than Laurie but also has
a beautiful connection you know there is
something beautiful about babysitting
adventures in babysitting
babysitters are not nannies
they are local girls and boys but local
girls who parents trust will watch over
their kids a lot of those babysitter's
couldn't drive you know nowadays all of
us are like well if they can't draw well
then I can't have them because well you
know I mean but this was like
neighborhood girls coming over so the
parents could go out to dinner or go to
a birthday party
there's just something beautiful about
the relationship between a babysitter
you're not a teacher you're not a
governess you're not Mary Poppins you're
appear in a weird way you know you're
only probably 8 to 10 years older than
the kids you're babysitting there's a
innocence about it all even though in
the new movie the sequence is terrifying
she's not an innocent girl this girl
clearly has you know it's a modern woman
you see here's what happened Laurie
Strode survived a brutal assault by an
unknown assailant and survived by her
wits and by the way had her life saved
by dr. Loomis the last minute there was
nothing for her there was no mental
health services offered I think she went
to school the next day do you know I
mean like I think her parents were those
Midwestern parents like honey you're
okay you got a little cut on your arm
got a band a you know a couple stitches
maybe she stayed home a day she went
back to school and she was the freak cuz
all she was was everybody looked at her
and nobody helped her and so all that
happened was that she lost everything
she lost herself she lost her friends
nobody was helping her everybody was
saying oh just get on with your life and
of course that didn't happen so then the
cascading trauma just it's like a
tumbleweed it just gets bigger and
bigger and bigger and so she slams into
people looking for contact men she's
marriage thing alcoholism drugs all of
it with no support
she was the freak she's the girl who
survived she's the final girl but she's
also something that you recoil from in a
way nobody went and embraced her and so
all of the innocence is gone and so she
has had she has been self-reliant and
the more callous that she created on
herself
the farther and farther people you know
came and she had a child and they took
the child away cuz can you imagine
Laurie Strode going into your first
grade
you know back-to-school night when all
the parents are going hi what is the
curriculum Laurie's going hi what's your
exit strategy well seriously now the
weird thing is of course today active
shooter is a term that everybody knows
in school but back in the day there was
none of that and so of course
Laurie who was just trying to protect
her daughter the authorities were called
because what kind of life is that for a
little girl so she was taken and again
compounded callous callous callous so
the woman we meet is alive by her own
wits has no friends is that the freak of
the town and lives in a compound because
she is preparing herself every day for
the eventualities that Michael Myers
will return and he does she's a survivor
of a night of horror and her character
in the new film PTSD and survivor's
guilt and all sorts of things she's a
mess
and that's what's so much fun about how
Jamie plays it and the new film is just
great this movie has nothing zero to do
with anything except Halloween 1978
period not even Halloween - the problem
is this your junk carpenter I'm Debra
hill and we're writing a movie together
and we write a movie and come up with
the story and it turns out to actually
do well so now they
or say well we want you to do another
one but now it's just a bunch of other
people's ideas what if what if what if
and all those what ifs is what has
filled 40 years and I'm not saying that
those what-ifs don't have value I'm not
saying that the movies that were made
about those what ifs aren't things that
people love is some love them some may
hate them to ride them whatever but
they're not there is no Bible there was
no big book like oh and sequel 10 laurie
is actually it's just not true it's all
what if I know what if it's her brother
that's good oh that's good and you write
a movie about it what was so beautiful
about the first movie is it was complete
you can't kill the boogeyman it was the
boogeyman as a matter of fact it was
that's beautiful he's gone
do-do-do-do-do-do to do just because
what it's saying is he's everywhere he
always will be everywhere it's
terrifying
so what's beautiful about the new movie
is that it removes all it just literally
slices away all of those other movies
they exist you can watch them you can
love them or hate them there's 1978
Halloween and 40 years later that's it
that's why this movie got me that's why
I said yes because it made all the sense
in the world take away any of the past
and even address it in the script you've
seen the trailer andy is walking to
school with her friends and miles Robin
says well yeah isn't it her brother and
she goes no that was something somebody
made up and done you see gone it's very
clean 1978 happened and now 40 years
later
18 is happening period Haddonfield was
West Hollywood and South Pasadena in
1978 in Haddonfield is Charleston South
Carolina and you know Ashley phosphate
Road out in the boonies of South
Carolina so there is no real Haddonfield
Haddonfield
was created to be all every town Laurie
Strode is every person every girl and it
was beautiful to return because the
tree-lined street in Charleston was the
same tree-lined street as in West
Hollywood because you see that is
ubiquitous babysitting is ubiquitous in
a sense even though we are shifted in
our innocence and the internet isn't
helping there is still innocence and
there are still kids and there are still
babysitters and people still maybe
believe in that possibility
self-reliance resilience
that
okay you can stop now as I start to cry
thank you all very much
[Music]
you